ja herzlich willkommen zu diesem späten
Panel dass ich noch mal mit dem Thema
beschäftigen wird das heute ja den
ganzen Tag immer
angesprochen wurde und dass uns seit
einem Jahr beschäftigt nämlich dem Krieg
in der Ukraine
mein Name ist Nicolas Buss ich bin der
auslandschef der FAZ und ich habe zwei
Gäste
eingeladen die beide nicht nur sehr
kompetent sind was dieses Thema betrifft
sondern auch an Entscheidungsprozessen
mitwirken was dann immer noch mal eine
andere Sache ist als wenn wir als
Journalisten Wissenschaftler oder
Zeitungsleser uns darüber Gedanken
machen
zu meiner Rechten begrüße ich den
Außenminister des großherzogstums
Luxemburg Jean Asselborn der eine wahre
Odyssee hinter sich hat dass er heute
neben uns sitzen kann der hat die
letzten Tage in Chile verbracht auf
einer Dienstreise da wollte er am Montag
hinfliegen und zwar von Frankfurt aus an
Frankfurt
streikten war aber Streik am Flughafen
also ist er von London ausgeflogen
bloß um uns dann anzurufen ein paar Tage
später von Chile aus und zu sagen dass
am Freitag in London am Flughafen
gestreikt wird
da ist er dann trotzdem noch heute
morgen gut angekommen und mit einigen
Tricks in einem Flugzeug nach Frankfurt
gekommen das hat in der Landung in
Frankfurt von einem Blitz getroffen
wurde
er hat's aber trotzdem geschafft
rechtzeitig hier anzukommen dafür bin
ich sehr dankbar herzlich willkommen
danke
haselborn ist seit 2004 der
Außenminister Luxemburg sehr sehr
dienstälteste Minister in Europa und hat
wenn ich das so frech sagen darf als
Vertreter eines mittelgroßen Landes
den Vorteil dass er vielleicht manchmal
nicht so diesen großen öffentlichen
Druck verspürt der auf anderen lastet
und das weiß ich weil wir kennen uns
schon ein paar Jahre deswegen zu einem
manchmal
abgewogeneren und trockeneren Urteil in
der Lage ist als die Leute die als die
großen Dompteure durch die politische
Arena laufen deswegen freue ich mich auf
das Gespräch
der andere Gast den wir zugeschaltet
haben ist andere Melnik der
stellvertretende Außenminister der
Ukraine
den muss man glaube ich in Deutschland
nicht vorstellen der hat mehr getan als
jeder Diplomat nach dem Zweiten
Weltkrieg in Deutschland um sich hier
bekannt zu machen
Herr Melnik war der bis zum Oktober der
Botschafter seines Landes in Berlin er
hatte dieses Amt in einer
öffentlichkeitswirksamen Art und Weise
versehen wie ich das noch nie erlebt
habe und ich bin jetzt auch schon zwei
drei Jahre in diesem Job
ist jetzt zurück in in Kiew was mich
sehr freut dass er die Zeit für uns
gefunden hat heute die Umstände sind bei
ihm natürlich noch mal dramatischer als
bei Herrn hasselborn deswegen konnte er
natürlich nicht selber hierher fahren
sondern wir haben ihn zugeschaltet ich
hoffe Sie verstehen uns gute Herren
guten Tag ich kann sie ganz gut hören
danke wir können Sie auch gut hören
wunderbar herzlich willkommen bei
unserer Runde
danke schön
Erik
erzählen sie uns mal wie das gewesen ist
im Oktober von Berlin von behüteten
Berlin mit der Familie zurück nach Kiew
in ein Kriegsland zu ziehen
ja das war eine Herausforderung die auch
jetzt Millionen Ukraine Tag und Nacht
seit genau 400 Tagen erleben müssen
gerade an dem Tag als ich in Kiefer
angekommen bin wurde ein Hochhaus
angegriffen und fünf Menschen sind zu
Tode gekommen und seitdem gehört das zu
Alltag auch für für uns sind für die
Familie und das heißt für uns alle auch
für für die Europäer für die deutschen
dass wir keine Zeit mehr verlieren
dürfen und die müssen diesen Krieg so
schnell wie möglich werden ich habe
zugehört als der Bundeskanzler gerade
gesprochen hat dass man davon hier
ausgeht dass er noch drei vier fünf
Jahre dauern kann damit wollen wir uns
nicht abfinden wir hoffen dass hier noch
in diesem Jahr Frieden erreichen können
dafür benötigen wir natürlich diese
Unterstützung dieser große Unterstützung
von unseren Verbündeten vor allem aus
Deutschland aber natürlich aus den USA
aus allen europäischen Staaten um Herrn
Putin und Russland zum Frieden zu
bewegen also wir wollen uns nicht jetzt
diesen blutigen sehr blutigen Kriegern
noch lange führen weil weil wir sowieso
schon so viele Opfer da bringen mussten
heute ist der Jahrestag als guter
befreit wurde ein Ort ein Vorort von von
Kik es sind keine 30 km zum realpalast
von hier in Kiel und da wurden
vier jahrhundert Leute innerhalb von 30
Tagen Besetzung können
ermordet auf eine brachiale Art und
Weise und das ist das was viele Ukraine
jetzt
behindert besessen Gebieten im Osten im
Süden erleben Tag und Nacht und das
können wir nicht mehr dulden das heißt
dass man ja nicht nur sagt man wird uns
solange unterstützen wie nötig dafür
sind wir sehr dankbar dass unsere
Partner uns unterstützen uns helfen aber
wir müssen alles unternehmen damit
dieser Krieg viel schneller noch in
diesem Jahr zu Ende ist denn so viele
Menschen mussten sterben und wir wollen
dieses Blut warte dass wir erleben viel
viel schneller beenden als manche denken
und das heißt natürlich dass man Gas
geben müsste dass man uns nicht nur
diese 18 Leopard fahren zwei Panzer die
wir gerade letzte Woche bekommen haben
zugeschickt hat sondern wir brauchen
leider Gottes viel viel mehr wir können
diesen Krieg nicht gewinnen also Mitte
mit diesen Waffen die unsere bis heute
geliefert wurde wir bereiten eine gegen
Offensive vor aber der Eindruck der
manchmal entsteht auch in Deutschland
ist als ob alles schon erledigt ist als
ob der Krieg bald zu Ende ist und das
stimmt leider nicht das stimmt leider
nicht wir müssen viel mehr tun wir
brauchen natürlich nach wie vor und
Unterstützung also mit der Luftwaffe
ohne ohne die Kampfjets aus den USA aus
Deutschland aus anderen europäischen
Staaten können wir diese Offensive nicht
erfolgreich starten und darum geht es es
geht um die Schnelligkeit wie schnell
Entscheidungen auch in Berlin oder vor
allem in Berlin getroffen werden
ja sie haben jetzt schon vieles was wir
was wir im einzelnen noch besprechen
wollten angesprochen ich darf Sie dafür
vielleicht doch noch mal zurückkommen zu
dem was ich am Anfang gefragt das ging
nicht nur um Sie persönlich sondern
können Sie uns vielleicht ein bisschen
einen Eindruck vermitteln ähm wie das
Leben in einer Stadt wie Kirche oder
auch ein Städten die noch ein bisschen
näher sind im nach einem Jahr in dieser
fürchterlichen Lage in der ihr Land sich
befindet sich jetzt ab
darstellen wie wie wie wie ist ihr
Alltag wie ist der Alltag der Leute wie
wie wie leben sie
also es ist ein sehr merkwürdiges Gefühl
muss man sagen man hat sich gewöhnt
leider an diesen Krieg das bedeutet dass
fast jeden Tag in Kiew sie reden heulen
Luftalarm wird verkündet ich habe das
auf meinem Smartphone wie die meisten
meine Landsleute aber man nimmt das
einfach locker man arbeitet weiter oder
man fährt weiterhin im Auto man muss
natürlich ein luftbunker suchen aber es
ist so dass wenn man dann wirklich jeder
Nacht und jede Nacht jede Nacht gab es
glaube ich zweimal Luft
und in der gesamten gesamten Ukraine da
wird man verrückt wenn man dann quasi in
die Tiefgarage laufen muss dort zwei
Stunden sitzen und dann zurückkehrt
darauf zählt auch Putin also mit dieser
perfekten Strategie dass die Menschen
auch seelisch und psychisch am Ende sind
dass die Menschen nicht mehr in der Lage
sind zu denken und das ist so die
Atmosphäre indem man leben in der
Millionen Ukraine jetzt seit 400 Tagen
und Nächte ausharren müssen eine Art
gewisse eine Normalität die verrückte
aussieht für viele aber es gibt ja keine
andere Wahl das ist das ist diese
traurige Realität auch jetzt mit einem
Kiew ist da was was passiert da mit der
Stimmung der Leute haben sie haben
dieses Gefühl dass da auch zum Teil so
eine depressiv depressive Anmutung
einkehrt dass die Leute
aufhören noch noch an den Erfolg zu
glauben oder oder oder macht einen das
eigentlich eher widerstandsfähiger also
eine eine gute Frage also ich glaube
dass jeder Ukrainer heute und nach dem
Krieg äh einen Psychologen vielleicht
ein Psychiater brauchen würde so ist es
halte aber im Moment ist die Stimmung
nach wie vor so dass die allermeisten
Ukraine ich glaube über 90% der Ukraine
fest entschlossen sind auch weiterhin
ihre Heimat zu zu verteidigen dass sie
auch einen Sieg der Ukraine glauben und
ein sie würde für uns natürlich bedeuten
dass wir alle besetzten Gebiete befreien
können unsere Armee ist in der Lage das
zu tun aber natürliche seelisch und
psychisch sind viele viele fast
ausgebrannte denn es ist eine eine
Zumutung also für für die Psyche jeden
Tag aufzustehen und jeden Tag ins Bett
zu gehen mit einem und denselben
Gedanken was wird morgen kommen werde
ich überhaupt jetzt lebendig aufwachen
wird eine Rakete mein Haus ähm treffen
oder nicht oder meine Nachbarn oder
meine Verwandten das sind so die
Gedanken die die sich immer im Kopf
kreisen und das betrifft Präsidenten ist
bis zu den Kindern und am meisten sind
die Kinder betroffen denn wenn also die
Schule darf das nicht ignorieren also
wenn Luftballon erklingt dann müssen
alle Kinder zu U-Bahn-Station laufen und
manchmal ist es so dass sie den ganzen
Schultag in tief in auf eine U-Bahn
Station in Kiew ausfahren müssen und das
macht schon zu schaffen also einiges an
der Generation der Kinder erlebt also in
diesem schwierigen
Alltag und deswegen möchte ich das auch
wiederholen
dass man sich auf einen langen Krieg
einstellen darf auch nicht in Europa man
muss alles unternehmen
militärisch aber auch vielleicht
diplomatisch um um diesen Schrecken
schneller zu beenden denn es ist schon
etwas Einmaliges was einem europäischen
Staat mitten im 21 Jahrhundert
zugestoßen ist dass wir uns auch jetzt
allmählich an diese schrecklichen Bilder
die in Botschaft gewöhnen und glauben ja
okay so ist es halt das das nicht
geschehen also wir dürfen nicht diese
Kreditkarte dass sie uns beherrscht und
das bedeutet auch für die Politik einen
neuen Ansatz dass man sich nicht
ausruhen darf auf den Lorbeeren man hat
uns sehr sehr stark geholfen das
schätzen wir das möchte ich auch heute
betonen dass die Ukraine ohne diese
Unterstützung der deutschen der
europäischen Freunde natürlich aus den
USA wer weiß wo heute Frontlinie
verlaufen würde aber es ist immer noch
nicht ausreichend wir brauchen nach wie
vor viel viel mehr um unsere Leute vor
allem unsere Leute zu befreien aus
diesem Joche und sind 18 %
des Staatsgebietes betroffen Prozente
der Ukraine sind jetzt unter unter
russische Besetzung das heißt ein Land
das so groß ist die Ostdeutschland muss
man sich vor Augen führen und das darf
man nicht mehr lange gedulden
also wenn Sie das Hören ähm diese
Geschichten da frage ich immer als
Sozialdemokrat sind der Sozialdemokratie
die Leute die Sozialdemokratie in Europa
vielleicht in Deutschland noch viel
stärker als im Rest von Europa aber in
Europa hat immer dran geglaubt man könne
einen kooperativen Ausgleich mit
Russland finden in der Art und Weise wie
wir den den Kontinent gestalten also
wenn man nicht zuhört und wenn man ja
auch natürlich also aus Minister weiß
was geschieht ich glaube nicht dass es
gut ist dann als Sozialdemokrat zu
schauen man muss als Mensch schauen als
Politiker schauen was kann man tun damit
dieses Leid für die ukrainische Menschen
aufhört und vielleicht
es ist ja so dass wir von Anfang an uns
auf eine Linie gesetzt haben dass wir
nicht als Europäische Union jetzt Krieg
führen können gegen Russland sondern uns
auf diesen Artikel 51 der schachtler der
Vereinten Nationen
bezogen haben der übrigens mit der
Sowjetunion ausgearbeitet wurde als die
Schachter der Vereinten Nationen gebaut
wurde und da steht klar ein Land wie die
Ukraine der das überfallen wird
und sich während kann und muss gegen den
ergasse auch eine Koalition einbeziehen
muss diese Koalition sind wir als
Europäische Union ihre erste Frage ist
natürlich und die andere Frage haben ja
sicher
also ich war
mit dem Vorgänger von dimitro in
mariopol und daran chirokino ich habe
das gesehen mit eigenen Augen doch für
die zerschossen wurden das waren nicht
weit weg von Mario polmanist von Kiew
mit einem Spezial Flugzeug dahin
gebracht worden nach mariopolen und hat
das gesehen wie das da aussah nach
selbstverständlich
2014 schon
Fehler ja aber wissen Sie das Problem
war ja dass wir in der Europäischen
Union und nicht nur Sozialdemokraten
sondern die aller allermeisten Länder
dran geglaubt haben dass man irgendwie
einen normalen tritt mit Russland finden
könnte
putin war in Luxemburg auf staatsbesite
wir in vielen Ländern war
2008 er sprach deutsch wie wir beide
jetzt Deutsch reden und ich hätte nie
gedacht zwei Stunden bei ihm ich hatte
nie geglaubt dass der so ein barbara ist
so ein Kriminaler ist der so ein Krieg
auch ich kann nicht so lange aus Mister
wie ich das ist ein Wandel stattgefunden
in der fast nicht zu erklären ist
ich war auch dabei muss ich Ihnen sagen
in 2008 in Bukarest an diesem berühmten
dann kommt ja immer die Frage wenn wir
damals das gemacht hätten wo die
Amerikaner also Busch hat gesagt okay
aber nicht zu viel gedrückt der am
meisten war ja Kaczynski also der die
Polen hätten wir damals die Ukraine in
die Nacht aufgenommen das war ja mit mit
Georgien was wäre dann geschehen und was
wäre nicht geschehen
Fehler haben wir glaube ich alle gemacht
ob Sozialdemokraten nicht
Sozialdemokraten ob deutsche Luxemburger
Franzosen das war nachdem was geschehen
ist auf der Krim dass wir da eigentlich
nicht
zusehen wollte nicht fühlen wollte nicht
spüren wollten was der nächste Schritt
sein könnte das ist der Fehler der
kapitale Fehler glaube ich der
unterlaufen ist aber
vorwerfen sagen wir mal der europäischen
Politik der Deutschen wieder
französischen widerspanischen dass man
nicht versucht hat mit allen Mitteln
dieses Russland dieses riesige Land auch
diesen Putin irgendwie auf die Schiene
zu bekommen denn die Mittelklasse in
Russland ist ja echt entstanden auch
durch die wirtschaftliche Kooperation
mit Europa mit der Europäischen Union
nicht mit China und auch nicht mit
irgendeinem anderen Land auf der Welt
da gebe ich schon zu aber sie haben
gesagt ich bin 2004 ausmister geworden
und ich hatte mir nie nie gedacht nie in
diesem Jahr und am Anfang wo ja auch das
war nach 2003 der Krieg im Irak aber es
gab trotzdem viel Hoffnung damals auch
zwischen Russland und Amerikanern dass
man auf ein anderes Schiene käme hat mir
nie nie vorstellen können so klar sogar
glaube ich im Jahre 2021 noch nicht das
tut den zu dieser tatfähig ist wenn man
überlegt er hat angefangen in Tier wurde
da gestoppt Butcher hat Wirtschaft Witze
aus Micha gesagt was das war dann jetzt
in diesem Winter wo nimmt der das Recht
her um die Infrastrukturen um Menschen
das Menschen warm in ihren Häusern sind
das Kinder warm zu Hause sind das alles
kaputt zu schlagen in mit welchem Recht
nimmt er das aus und bin ich absolut
einverstanden ich glaube wir müssen
weiter in der Europäischen Union alles
tun es ist ich höre jetzt auf aber sieht
sehr viel geschehen zum Beispiel das
letzte Entscheidung die wir getroffen
haben das zehnte Sanktionspaket aber vor
allem dass wir Munition jetzt ankurbeln
ich habe mit Tierrettung auch sprechen
können vor kurzem bei der NATO er ist
sehr involviert was der Bundeskanzler
gesagt das ist ja auf Deutschland vor
allem aber auch in osteuropäischen
Länder dass die Munition
dass die angekurbelt wird leider man
muss man muss ja sagen Außenminister die
sagen das wichtigste sich Munition das
ist eine andere Welt ausmisten sind ja
werden ja bezahlt so wie Ärzte bezahlt
werden um Leben zu retten sind die
ausmisten bezahlt damit Frieden entsteht
und aber der Krieg da glaube ich bin ich
mit ihnen auch einverstanden der kriegt
wird wahrscheinlich nicht gewonnen auf
dem Schlachtfeld aber er kann verloren
werden auf dem Schlacht Feld und darum
ist das so wichtig dass wir der auch
keine stehen aber Wasser
[Applaus]
sagt wir tun nicht immer noch nicht
genug das muss schneller gehen und er
sagt das muss in diesem Jahr noch
passieren also in diesem Jahr den Krieg
zu einem Ende zu bringen ist das ist das
aus ihrer Sicht realistisch ja dass man
dass man den Krieg in diesem Jahr zu
Ende bringen kann um B dass der
politische Wille und auch die
materiellen Kapazitäten im Westen
vorhanden sind um zu diesem Ergebnis zu
kommen also ich bin mit dem Auto jetzt
fahre ich von Luxemburg nach von
Frankfurt nach Luxemburg wenn ich in
Luxemburg ankomme gibt es einen Menschen
der den Krieg schon werden könnte der
hat
das ist der der direkt den Krieg werden
könnte militärisch also ich bin kein
Experte aber man sieht doch dass die
Linien total
zugefroren sind wenn man wenn das stimmt
wenn man nicht sie haben bestimmt
bessere Zahlen aber in in diesem in
dieser wie heißt das
ist ja schrecklich wie viele Leute da
ihr Leben verlieren höchstwahrscheinlich
auch sehr viele Ukrainer warum warum
muss man sich vorstellen und darum nur
einmal in der Europäischen Union ich
kann mich erinnern die ersten Reaktionen
Schweden Finnland das hat glaube ich mai
bis Mai 21 bis wir bis sie geredet haben
wir wollen uns trotzdem
ich glaube dass dann glaube ich auch
diese ganzen Debatte die wir hatten am
Anfang Sanktionen das ging schnell es
sind Fehler gemacht worden dieser Kyrill
kauft gehört auf die Liste aber das ist
Europäische Union ein Land kann sowas
verhindern aber im Wesentlichen haben
wir trotzdem da dann kam die Geschichte
mit den Waffen ja die Geschichte diese
ganze Debatte mit den Waffen am Anfang
hat man gesagt nur letal Waffe nicht
tödliche Waffen dann wir müssen der
Ukraine helfen wir können nicht
zuschauen dass die Menschen in der
Ukraine abgeschlachtet werden und wir
sprechen hier von großen Theorien dann
haben wir uns entschieden zuerst ja mit
Waffenlieferungen dann kam die
Diskussion über über die Panzer die
glaube ich aber trotzdem auch wenn die
Frage die gestellt werden Bundeskanzler
glaube ich dass die aber gut behandelt
wurde von Deutschland und dass ich hoffe
dass die anderen nachziehen die das auch
wir haben jetzt mit Flugzeuge das sind
ja Flugzeuge die von den ukrainischen
bluten auch können
gefahren werden also geflogen werden aus
der Slowakei und aus Polen
glaube ich ist dann ein guter Anfang
über über andere Flugzeuge denkt ja auch
Großbritannien nach auch Amerika ich
weiß auch das muss stimmen die
Informationen das 11.000 ukrainische
Soldaten ausgebildet werden zurzeit in
der Europäischen Union in Deutschland
fast sehr wichtig ist dass ukrainische
Ärzte die vor Ort operieren können dass
die zurzeit auch in Ländern wie
Deutschland und auch in anderen Ländern
ausgebildet werden das sind Sachen die
die Europäische Union tun kann ich bin
jetzt überfragt ob der Krieg der keine
zu gewinnen ist wenn wir massiv
Kampfflugzeuge einsetzen jede Waffe die
wir bis jetzt eingesetzt haben wo wir
uns aus Europäische Union angebracht
haben war ja nicht um Russland
anzugreifen sondern war um
dass die keine sich wehren kann dass die
keine sich verteidigen kann und ich
hoffe noch immer das dieser Putin
einsieht dass er diesen Krieg nicht
militärisch gewinnen kann das müsst ihr
einsehen und er müssen dann auch
einsehen dass wir zusammenkommen als
international Gemeinschaft unter der
Führung der UNO unter der Führung der
UNO und nicht den lokalen und
irgendetwas aufzwingen die auch keine
haben das Recht und sie haben das ja in
Bali auch klar gesagt ihr Präsident die
Souveränität muss garantiert werden die
Russen müssen wegziehen und dann soll
man reden wie man in Zukunft
selbstverständlich zu Realität das
Landes garantiert und wie man natürlich
auch solche Interventionen wie sie jetzt
kommen wie die vermieden werden können
ich bin auch ein letztes Wort über China
am Anfang habe ich mir gedacht wenn ein
Land eingreifen kann und ähm sagen wir
mal vermitteln kann dann ist das für
eine Großmacht die China sieht sich auf
derselben Stufe wie die Amerikaner und
wenn sie aber trotzdem sagen
als sie singen in Moskau war da sieht
man wer der Koch ist und wer der Kellner
ist der Mann ein Wort von einem
deutschen Kanzler zu benutzen und die
Chinesen profitieren ja auch sehr sehr
von diesem von diesem Leid was die
keiner haben ich hoffe dass es nicht
dazu kommt dass
chinesische Waffen geliefert werden auch
keine Drohnen geliefert werden ich hoffe
das sehr dann das würde unser Verhältnis
und ich denke daran Deutschland vor
allem
total auf den Kopf stellen sie wissen
dass wir Sanktionen ihre technischen
Union entschieden haben gegen den Iran
dann könnte etwas paralleles geschehen
auch oder müsste sogar geschehen wenn
das stimmt gegen China also China darf
man nicht einfach in die Ecke drücken
sie haben diesen Plan aber dieser Plan
spricht von der Souveränität sagt aber
nicht dass die Russen müssten die
Souveränität der Ukraine auch
garantieren man soll das nicht total
ignorieren aber das ist zurzeit auf
einer Schiene wo man sagen kann dass
China eigentlich eine pro russische
Neutralität vorspielt
dieses dieses
Format hier lebt davon dass sie Fragen
stellen können ich möchte aber Herrn
Melnik vorher noch eine Sache fragen was
Herr Asselborn gerade gesagt hat er
hofft darauf dass es Putin irgendwann
mal einzieht ist das was auch ihre
Hoffnung ist anders gefragt wie kommt
man wie kommt man aus diesem das ist
eine Frage die sich hier viele in
Deutschland stellen wie gibt es auch
eine diplomatischen Weg raus aus diesem
Krieg
also die Ukraine
sind ja diejenigen die am meisten den
Frieden wollen uns wurde ja vorgeworfen
wir sind hier alle kriegsheil und so
weiter das stimmt nicht also wir wollen
nur unsere Heimat und das heißt auch
unsere Existenz verteidigen und retten
vor diesem Krieg und deswegen sind wir
natürlich auch bereit alles mögliche zu
Unternehmen im Moment ist es leider nur
auf dem Schlachtfeld möglich aber dann
auch die problematisch um eine
friedliche Lösung zu erreichen ob das
realistisch ist eine eine gute Frage wir
glauben dass sowohl militärisch als auch
was die Sanktionen angetete noch sehr
sehr viel Luft nach oben gibt
Außenminister geworden hat das zehnte
sanktions Paket erwähnt wir sind sehr
dankbar für diese Punkte unsere
verbunden hier in der EU in der NATO
aber wenn wir ähnliche Präsente da gibt
es immer noch zu viele Schlupflöcher
russische
Nuklearindustrie Atom
Atomindustrie ist immer noch nicht
betroffen viele Banken sind die aus
geschlossen vom Swift zu System und so
weiter es gibt nach wie vor sehr viel ja
Unternehmen könnte aber auch heute beim
Thema Energie
Importe oder Export aus Russland
um unsere Wirtschaft noch mehr unter
Druck zu setzen und das würde bedeuten
dass Brötchen dann eines Tages doch
nicht mehr Geld hat um diesen Krieg
vorzusetzen das heißt auch da gibt es
noch einiges was man tun könnte mit der
Hilfe unsere europäischen unsere
transatlantischen Freunde kein Thema und
wir hoffen dass die Europäer das auch
einsehen dass man
das 11 Paket ist in der Arbeit
ja danke das ist sehr wichtig zu zu
hören und aber auch das Thema
Schnelligkeit ich möchte das auch
wiederholen spielte eine Rolle wir
dürfen keine Zeit mehr verlieren auch
beim Thema was von Deutschland hat einen
Quantensprung gemacht beim Thema
Waffenlieferungen wir sind dafür sehr
dankbar aber es gibt nach wie vor viele
rote Linien und ich glaube in der
Situation
in der sich jetzt Millionen Ukraine
befinden darf das keine rote Linien
ergeben so sowohl weil es was Neues
Sanktionen angeht als auch was diese
militärische Hilfe betrifft und ich
möchte nochmals wiederholen ohne Kampf
äh jetze aus dem Westen ohne
Kriegsschiffe wird das sehr sehr
schwierig sein die Gebiete die besetzt
sind zu befreien und wir möchten ja
keine gegen Offensive starten die nicht
vorbereitet ist also wir haben halt so
knapp jetzt 50 60 Kampfpanzer aus dem
Westen aber die Russen sind nach wie vor
in der Lage jeden Tag zehn Panzer zu
bauen oder Instand zu setzen und das
heißt wir wir werden noch lange Zeit
nicht in der Lage sein einen
entscheidenden Vorteil auf dem
schlagfeld zu gewinnen und das heißt
dass die militärische Hilfe die Munition
ist auch hier kritisch danke
Außenminister für dafür dass sie das
angesprochen haben Munition ist
natürlich für unsere auch eine wichtige
Voraussetzung dass wir diesen
Verteidigungskrieg vorsetzen können aber
es darf nicht ewig sein wir müssen
schauen wie wir diplomatisch auf
Russland einwirken es gibt viele
Möglichkeiten auch China könnte hier
vielleicht doch eine konstruktive Rolle
spielen
bei bei allem was wir vorher bis jetzt
gesehen haben wir müssen alles in
Bewegung setzen wir müssen wirklich alle
einsetzen um auch diplomatisch auf Boden
damit er noch in diesem Jahr auch hört
er meldet dafür vielleicht noch kurz
anfangen weil wir waren ja bei der
diplomatischen Frage können Sie sich ein
Szenario vorstellen indem die Ukraine
einer in welcher Form auch immer Gebiete
aufgibt um den Krieg zu beenden
also im Moment stellt sich diese Frage
gar nicht deswegen würde ich auch nicht
dann spekulieren den wir müssen jetzt
diese Chance und diese Chance ist
wirklich jetzt einmalig in diesem Jahr
alles auf eine Karte zu setzen und zu
beweisen und selbst aber auch unseren
Partnern dass wir dass unsere Armee
Verlage Äste die Gebiete zu befreien
also darum geht es im Moment wie eine
diplomatische Lösung aussieht steht im
Moment noch in den Sternen aber auch da
wird nicht an an uns liegen um einen
Frieden zu erreichen es es kommt darauf
an dass wir auch eine neuen vielleicht
noch eine schlimmeren Kriege verändern
müssen und er sollte heute darüber
gesprochen werden wie ein ein neuer
Kriege mit Russland
vermieten werden kann das heißt dass die
Ukraine auch Garantien bekommen sollte
und die beste Garantie wäre her
Außenminister Aussehen worden hat das
angesprochen das Thema NATO ist aus
unserer Sicht und da sind auch die
Finnen und die Schweden davon auch
überzeugt die einzige Machbare Option
und wir hoffen das gleich nachdem dieses
Krieg zu Ende ist dass die Ukraine in
die NATO aufgenommen wird das wäre aus
unserer Sicht die einzige die einzige
Option um einen neuen Krieg ähm der aus
Russland vielleicht vorbereitet werden
kann
für Ewigkeit zu verhindern
also zuerst will ich noch sagen als
nicht Deutscher in deutscher Sprache zu
den Waffen etwas sagen ich habe ja
gehört was in Berlin diese Demonstration
man darf das ist unehrlich den Menschen
zu sagen dass Waffenlieferungen um sich
zu wehren in die Ukraine den Krieg
verlängern würde das ist unehrlich ja
wenn keine Sache
was ich sagen wollte ist wenn keine
Waffen geliefert würden aus Europa aus
Amerika vielleicht auch Kanada dann wäre
der Krieg vorüber
aber es gäbe keine Ukraine mehr es wäre
kein Witz aus Mister mehr der Ukraine
hier am Bildschirm und
Putin stünde an der Grenze zu Polen
und fährt in eine Staatswirtschaft
Luxemburg vor zwei Wochen in Lettland
man muss sich die Geschichte dieser
Länder anschauen
zuerst Stalin dann Hitler dann wieder
Sowjetunion die Angst die diese Menschen
haben im Kopf und das einzige das
einzige
ich verstehe sie das einzige was ja in
den Köpfen der Menschen in Europa eine
gewisse gab die bietet ist die Nato und
darum hat Putin etwas vollbracht was wir
Europäer und mit den Amerikanern
überhaupt nicht vollbracht haben wir
haben die UNO die die Natur
zusammengeschweißt jetzt ist praktisch
ich hoffe dass Herr Erdogan auch einmal
vom Rost herunter kommt oder ein anderer
ja man spielt man spielt Erdogan spielt
mit der Angst der Menschen in Schweden
die Bedingungen erstellt kann Schweden
nie als Rechtsstaat vorgeleisen
unmöglich das ist ja dieses sitzt hier
entscheidet wer ausgeliefert werden so
er hat also etwas vollbracht
ist ja nicht so lange her
ich habe auch Trump erlebt in der in der
in der in der NATO das war also wenn man
diesen Film gezeigt hätte wie das in der
Sitzung zugehen mit seinen zwei Prozent
und mit anderen
Angriffen auf praktisch jedes Land und
dann hat er ja auch gesagt die NATO wäre
obsolet
die Gegenreaktion war ja dann das war
auf die Türkei eigentlich von macron
dass die NATO hirntot wäre also all das
ist vorüber und ich glaube die einzige
so die Frage war kommt die Ukraine in
die Nato und vanic hat vorher ein Satz
gesagt und auf den müssen wir uns jetzt
konzentrieren wenn der Krieg vorüber ist
dann so
ich hoffe auch dass wir es hinbekommen
wenn der Krieg vorüber ist oder
vielleicht sogar parallel dass wir auch
die europäische Frage gelöst bekommen
wir müssen nur wissen in der
europäischen Frage Mitglied Fernseher
Europäischen Union da gibt's einen
Prozess die Länder die am wenigsten Zeit
gebraucht haben bis jetzt war Litauen
und nur ein Land aus dem Slowakei und
Malta 5 Jahre 5 Jahre das habe ich jetzt
ein Minimum was gebraucht wurde von
Ländern um mich zu werden Europäischen
Union aber man muss sagen dass in der
Ukraine ganz viel gearbeitet wird in
justizfragen in korruptionsfragen und so
weiter in einer sehr schwierigen
Situation und die Kommission wird ja
jetzt im Frühjahr auch ihre Begutachtung
geben und ich glaube da auch dass wir
Ende des Jahres wissen wo wir dran sind
aber das geht schon parallel ich glaube
die europäische wir müssen wissen dass
in der Europäischen Union und in der der
NATO nach diesem Krieg der hoffentlich
zu Ende geht egal wie jetzt zu Ende geht
aber die wo keine muss bestehen bleiben
dass wir dann auch schauen müssen auf
diesen zwei Ebenen die du keine
einzubinden
ich sehe meinen Chef das heißt meine
Zeit läuft ab
auf der Uhr sind es noch fünf Minuten
ich würde würde sie einladen ein paar
Fragen zu stellen
aber sie wissen es dass Scheiße
sie dürfen gerne Fragen stellen sich
kurz vor die Frage möglichst kurz und
die Antworten auch mit sich kurz bitte
nein mein Name ist Edgar Salzmann und
ich würde gerne mit einem Lob Starten
der mannig sind ja auch teilweise
kritisiert worden dafür dass sie mal von
der beleidigten Leberwurst gesprochen
haben ich finde grundsätzlich sehr
besonders gut gemacht man muss in
solchen Situationen wirklich laut sein
um Aufmerksamkeit zu kriegen bestimmt
haben Sie auch nicht immer gerne gemacht
aber ich glaube sie haben das gut
gemacht insofern einmal ein Lob an sie
und die zweite Frage die stellen wollen
würde ist was können wir hier in
Deutschland im Sinne von Kommunikation
von ihnen lernen wie Sie es schaffen den
Spirit in der Ukraine aufrecht zu
erhalten damit weiter das Volk so hinter
ihnen steht
also danke für für für ihre lobenden
Worte in der Tat es ist nicht angenehm
wenn ein Diplomat schreien musste
Außenminister gerade erwähnt es ist
nicht gewöhnlich wenn Außenminister über
Waffen und Munition beraten müssen aber
es war eine
schicksalate Zeit vor vor 13 Monaten als
der Krieg Aussprache und es gab aus
unserer Sicht gar keine andere Wahl als
äh laut zu werden um eben diese
Aufmerksamkeit zu schaffen denn sie
werden sich erinnern dass das keine in
Europa uns eine Chance gegeben hatte
mehr als ein paar Tage vielleicht ein
paar Wochen durchzuhalten und jetzt sind
das über 400 Tage das
dass die Riesen sehr sehr blutigen
Verteidigungskrieg
führen muss und für uns geht es nach wie
vor um das Überleben also da das ist
quasi alle nicht nur die Armee aber auch
die Zivilgesellschaft auch das Parlament
die Regierung alle Menschen bewegt und
motiviert weiterhin zu kämpfen denn wenn
wir auch hören müssen dann dann würde
das bedeuten dass wir verschwinden als
Nation als politische Nation ähm dass
wir aus der Karte getilgt werden und das
dürfen wir Nichten zu lassen und
deswegen möchte ich vielleicht ganz
kurze anschließend an die Frage von oder
an das Thema was der erste geworden
angesprochen hat
EU-Mitgliedschaft ist für uns von einer
enormen Bedeutung und wir hoffen dass
die Ukraine und das unsere europäischen
Partner noch in die ähm weiteres
Verhandlungen starten können wir sind in
der Lage auch mit einem Kriege unsere
Hausaufgaben zu lösen
wir können tun und auch das ist ein ein
eine Garantie vielleicht dass wir nach
nachdem diese Krieg zu Ende ist dass wir
als als Mitglied nicht nur in der NATO
sondern auch in der EU ein Bestandteil
diese diese Familie werden und dass wir
auch einen Beitrag leisten wir haben
gezeigt dass wir eine starke Armee haben
und unsere osteuropäischen Nachbarn die
beiden die Polen die wissen dass Sie auf
unsere sich verlassen können dass wir
zur Hilfe einen werden im Ernstfall im
Kriegsfall und das ist etwas was man
nicht vergessen darf wir wollen nicht
nur Nutzen sein von diese Mitgliedschaft
damit ein neuer Krieg verändert wird
sondern wir wollen auch einen Beitrag
leisten und genauso auch was die
Wissenschaft angeht unsere Wirtschaft
ist eingebrochen 30% haben wir im
letzten Jahr verloren wegen des Krieges
aber wir haben auch diesen Crashtest
bestanden wir haben diese Resilienz
gezeigt demonstriert dass wir nach wie
vor als stark funktionieren dass
demokratische Strukturen da sind dass
das Parlament arbeiten dass der Gerichte
nach wie vor ihre Arbeit erledigen und
das ein Beispiel dass man auch in einer
Situation die fast aussichtslos aussieht
für die Außenwelt dass wir in der Lage
sind zu überleben und das ist auch ein
Beispiel für unsere Freunde in der EU
[Applaus]
da hinten bitte
in Ostdeutschland sind aber aus
Westdeutschland und verfolgen sehr wohl
die ganze Stimmung auch in
Ostdeutschland wir haben ja dort eine
Menge von sogenannten Russland verstehen
also der Melanie lass uns doch nicht so
sehr über die Zeit nach der nach dem
Frieden reden sondern wie kann der
Frieden erreicht werden eine Frage mal
als Alternative was hat es eigentlich
mit dem Cyberkrieg auf sich sie sind
doch so unheimlich stark in der
Kommunikation und verfügen wir sehr
viele Mittel unsere Frage mal wieso kann
nicht aus dem internen Kreis der
Oligarchen aus Putins innerem Umfeld
wieso kann ich im weiteren Umfeld dort
eine Stimmung erzeugt werden die also
eindeutig die Opposition vertritt wieso
kann im Putin nicht aus diesem Kreis
heraus mehr mehr an Drohung mehr an an
Klarheit verschafft werden du kannst den
Krieg nicht gewinnen also versucht Dich
lieber rechtzeitig zu organisieren zur
Zeit würde das ja wohl nicht tun also
was ist mit den Oligarchen los wie ist
das Innere Netz sein es macht Zirkels
irgendwie anzugreifen wenn ich sogar zu
zerstören
auch eine sehr sehr gute Frage wir
glauben dass der Schaden der uns
zugefügt wurde im Laufe dieses
Vernichtungskrieges und da reden wir
über 100 Hunderte von Milliarden Euro
bis heute das dafür Russland nicht nur
die Regierung aber auch die Oligarchen
in Russland auch kommen müssen und da
gibt es dann schon ein Gewissen
Vorschritt das Geld eingefroren werden
in Europa in der westlichen Welt aber
dieses dieses Vermögen zu beschlagen
haben da gibt es sehr sehr viele Hürden
nach wie vor auch in Deutschland
dazu müsste vielleicht auch das
Grundgesetz geändert werden und wir
hoffen wir hoffen dass das auch diese
Erkenntnis hier konnte dass man noch
viele andere Mittel einsetzen sollte um
diese machte
um ein Putin herum noch noch
schmerzhafter zu treffen um eben diese
Dynamik zu erzeugen denn wir haben
leider erkannt dass es die Menschen in
Russland aus vielen Gründen nicht bereit
sind gegen ein Putin zu demonstrieren
das ist eine bittere Erkenntnis für uns
alle aber diejenige zu treffen die an
Macht schalten die nach wie vor
mitentscheiden dass diese kriegt da gibt
es noch viele Möglichkeiten die wir und
unsere Freunde in Europa in den USA noch
nutzen können um einen diplomatischen
Regel wenn man so will diesen Krieg ähm
zu beenden da hoffen wir das wird noch
einiges gemeinsam unternehmen können
darf ich auf europäischer Sicht etwas
sagen zu der zum Geld also wo wir eine
Handhabe haben als Europäische Union und
die Kommission ist im Griff das
Zuschauen es sind die Gelder der
russischen Zentralbank da ist eine
Möglichkeit was wir sind in einem
rechter fast schwieriger ist nehmen sie
mein Land es sind 5,5 Milliarden Gelder
blockiert der Wiederaufbau wird
geschätzt der Ukraine kostet etwa 750
Milliarden es ist jetzt eine Konferenz
in London ich glaube im April wo es um
den Wiederaufbau geht auch um um
Zuwendungen zu bekommen aber es kann
nicht sein dass Gelder von diesen
oligarschen was Sie gesagt haben die
gefroren sind dass man da nicht einen
Weg finden natürlich einen rechtlichen
Weg das muss mit dem recht lange sein
dass diese Gelder auch dann benutzt
werden können um diesen ganzen schade
der zugerichtet wurde von den Russen
auch verglichen werden kann ich bin
jetzt nicht weit weg von der sieberfrage
das Problem ist ein anderes glaube ich
über die lieber fragen hinaus gibt es in
Russland ein Anzeichen dass diese
vertikale Struktur die ausgeht von Putin
und bis nach unten geht zur glaube ich
zu jedem anderen Russen um die zu
durchbrechen und wir sehen was unsere
Informationen angeht keinen Ansatz dazu
und die Menschen unterstützen ich weiß
nicht ob das ehrlich ist oder was aus
Angst ist all diese Umfrage die gemacht
werden sagen ja das mehr als 70% Putin
noch immer unterstützen aber man weiß
wenn man diese Bilder auch der letzten
Woche sieht wie schrecklicher Sicht das
Väter deren Kinderzeichnungen machen
dass die ins Gefängnis kommen man weiß
dass das ein Regime ist das glaube ich
noch polizeilicher durchsetzt ist als es
die Lehrer oder sogar die Sowjetunion
also und darum es ist schwer
herauszufinden wie die Stimmung
eigentlich im Grunde genommen in das
sagen uns natürlich auch unsere
europäischen Botschafter in Russland
schwer herauszufinden ja
[Applaus]
hier vorne waren noch würde ich noch
eine
wir nehmen auch den Herrn hier und
die beiden da hinten ab vielleicht
machen wir die Fragen alle zusammen und
sie beantworten die dann um Block machen
Sie es bitte kurz ja vorhin stellte eine
junge Dame von da hinten glaube ich eine
Frage an den Bundeskanzler die ich gerne
an Sie richten möchte Herr Melnik was
können wir also nicht unsere Regierungen
sondern die Bürgerinnen und Bürger
dieses Landes respektive vielleicht der
Europäischen Union für die Ukraine tun
also danke für die Frage und für das
Angebot wir sind angewiesen auch auf
dieser Unterstützung denn wir können nur
schwer die Hausaufgaben erledigen um
eben Mitgliedschaft und auch die Nase
später dann so zur zu erreichen wir wir
sind auf diesem Weg gehen wir wir
versuchen das natürlich so schnell wie
möglich zu Menschen aber aber da
brauchen wir natürlich und da rede ich
vor allem auch über die Kommunalebene
über die Landesregierungen die uns
in Kirche helfen könnten die
hausverbesserung und ganz konkrete Dinge
es gibt es Kälte das gesamte Kommunität
das heißt die Gesetzgebung der EU
anzugleichen sondern auch zu übernehmen
um wirklich
fit zu sein für die Mitgliedschaft und
da da wird nicht genug sein dass wir
diese Unterstützung nur jeweiligen
Regierungen aus den EU-Staaten bekommen
sondern das auch auf der Ebene der
Bürger der Wissenschaften das wie eine
vielleicht eine allianze brauchen um da
zu schauen wie kann der Ukraine gerade
jetzt auch mitten im Krieg ähm noch
schneller und effektive geholfen werden
damit wir damit wir vielleicht nicht in
5 Jahren die manche Kandidaten gebraucht
werden sondern vielleicht in vier Jahren
fertig sind und dann sagen können ja wir
haben alles unternommen wir äh wir
können unsere Hand anstrecken und wir
können auch einen weiteren leisten als
nach wie vor dass der betrachtet größte
Land in Europa
dass wir diese EU von übermorgen stärken
können dass wir einen Beitrag leisten
sie haben gesehen Ukraine die in
Deutschland sind das sind sehr fähige
Menschen die die
wollen etwas erreichen und zeigen und
wir wir können die Ukraine kann die EU
von übermorgen viel viel
älter machen und darum geht es es geht
um eine gemeinsame Aufgabe und unsere
deutschen Freunde unsere werden
Wissenschaft profitieren es liegt auch
im ureigenen Interesse der
Bundesrepublik
so jetzt versuchen wir das mit den
beiden letzten Fragen beenden sehr
geehrter manik ich habe eine Aussage von
ihnen in der Talkshow gehört und erst
möchte
sehr guten Job gemacht aber sie haben
gesagt alle Russen sein
Feinde der Ukraine und ähm in Bezug auf
das was Herr Asselborn im gesagt hat
dass ja auch
in einer in der Russischen Föderation es
vielleicht Demos gibt oder oder
versuchte Demos und die sehr repressiv
niedergeschlagen werden wie
begründen sie das und warum haben sie
das gesagt was für eine
klare Aussage
ja danke für für die Frage und für ihre
Worte in der Tat das ist eine sehr sehr
bittere Feststellung die wir ja vor
einem machen mussten und leider ist es
so dass wir zu dieser Aussage stehen
müssen denn solange dieser kriegt
solange Menschen Zivilisten
ermordet werden auf dem Schlachtfeld
oder einfach in dem in diesem Raketen
Hagel denn wir fast tägliche Leben
müssen oder jede Nacht besser gesagt da
fällt es schwer auf Russland zu sehen
als auf eine freundliche Nation aber ich
bin davon überzeugt und das möchte ich
auch hervorheben dass Zeit kommen wird
nachdem dieser Krieg zu Ende ist nachdem
alle Fragen des Wiederaufbaus oder der
Reparationen
erledigt sind nachdem und auch darum an
diesem ist wichtig nachdem alle
Kriegsverbrecher zu Rechenschaft gezogen
werden die er in Butter gemordet haben
und in anderen Städten in der Ukraine
nachdem die russische Staatsführung sich
entschuldigte
wird auch söhnung gekommen das hat ja
Deutschland und Frankreich auch nach dem
zweiten Welt erlebte auch das hat Jahre
oder sogar jetzt zehnte gedauert jetzt
wieder in der EU als Freunde als Partner
als Verbündete da sind und ich bin
überzeugt dass auch diese Zeit dass auf
diese Zeit kommen wird und dass wir auch
meine Generation das noch erleben wird
aber im Moment gilt es alles zu
unternehmen um den Krieg zu beenden und
das ist quasi jetzt die die Hauptaufgabe
die für uns auch vor von Europäern von
deutschen steht
und es läuft leider die Zeit ein wenig
davon es war
[Applaus]
glaube das tut mir leid dass ich dass
ich jetzt keine weiteren Fragen zu
lassen kann glaube es war ein ganz gutes
Schlusswort ich danke Ihnen dass Sie an
dem späten Nachmittag jetzt noch so
lange ausgehalten haben ich glaube wir
sind belohnt worden mit einer guten
Diskussion ich danke Herrn Asselborn und
herrenik für ihre Teilnahme herrnik
wünsche ich alles Gute viel Kraft und
vor allem Gesundheit für ihn und seine
Familie und Herrn Asselborn wünsche ich
eine gute Heimreise
[Applaus]